[Music]
tick tock faces an investigation into
its impact on young people's mental
health
coalition of state attorneys from
california florida look at california
and florida get on the same team
look at this maybe something good is
happening the world's coming together
kentucky california and florida and
kentucky same page i'm calling this a
win already
and moore is investigating tick tock for
its potential effect on young people's
mental and physical health
group of ag's is looking to see the way
tic toc designs operates and markets its
platform has a negative effect on
children teens and young adults health
according to press release by the ag of
massachusetts so
um a couple of things that i find
troubling about tick tock and again if
me ranting about social media is no big
news but this is this is more personal
for me
um
my i have a middle schooler and
he came home and was talking about what
is this tick tock thing because of
course he lives in the 14th century
because he lives in our house and all of
his classmates are on tick-tock and did
he just have an abacus he placed with at
home that's what i'm picturing at the
house he has a stick and a small stone
and that's pretty much his toys and he
uh
he i said what are some things your
friends tell you about and so he gave us
the name of somebody on tick tock a tick
tock star and so my wife and i pull it
up and it was
again
i
my entire show is
is about relationships and sexuality
intimacy i am
far from an old-fashioned prude right
what i saw on that was a
very young kid
super provocative super um
it was just highly it was it was it
reminded me of my time working with
sexually abused kids it was highly
sexually charged up and it was really
young kids doing these dances
and it wasn't just
fun hilarious tic toc dances which i've
seen i've been a part of those this is
something totally different and
my initial thought was i don't want my
kids exposed to this and i don't want my
kids
longing to
become the topic of conversation
and i started to ask myself what is the
trajectory here for this product for
tick-tock and i realized that it's
different so
you know remember saturday morning
cartoons um we had those back in the uh
dinosaur era that's the only thing we
have in common age-wise we both had
cartoons um they you know they had these
shiny cereals and cool toys and things
like that that they had you know whiz
bang and and lots of shiny moments so
that kids would want to buy those
but the whole object of those
commercials was to get your kids to tell
your parents that's what i want they
still had to loot back to the parents
and this feels new because what this is
doing is going to aft directly after the
kids it's bypassing any sort of um wise
or mature
filter going directly into the hearts
and minds of kids
and that feels different and i'm happy
to see
states coming together states that on
the surface don't like each other are
coming together to say hey
um they write here how tick tock keeps
people watching and engaging is somewhat
mysterious they have had to pay millions
of dollars in fines
um tick tock has already for how they're
going after children under the age of
13.
um
man i
as somebody who doesn't consume tick
tock regularly
um help me out with the redeeming value
i can help you john so
to to tic toc's defense i am a big
consumer those words have never been
uttered in the history of the english
language by the way here's the thing uh
you know a lot of people assume tick
tock is a bunch of salacious dance
challenges but what's extra dangerous is
how good the algorithm is at learning
what you like okay and so it doesn't ask
you there's no survey that says hey
george are you interested in personal
finance and food hacks it didn't ask me
that it just learned over time the kind
of content i was engaging in so i don't
see dance challenges what i see is a lot
of content creators you know trying to
build their followings trying to sell an
online course whatever you know a lot of
the bitcoin bros that are out there
trying to teach you on whatever the next
coin you should invest in
so i do see a lot of value in
short form content creation it's where
things are going it's where we've been
heading we we have a shorter attention
span than ever and even the cartoons
these days if you watch them there's a
new scene change every three or four
seconds because it's just bright garbage
and you need to keep your attention by
switching scenes cutting cameras we are
losing our attention span so that to me
is one of the most dangerous parts it's
not the salacious dance challenges it's
the fact that i can't focus anymore i
can't even sit through a two-hour movie
yeah because i gotta oh where's my phone
i can't drive to the grocery store
without trying to text and drive and get
emails so to me the the danger is in
what short form content could be doing
to our attention spans to our focus and
that's that's we can't pay attention to
conversations anymore it's a
neurological consequence right it's
changing how our brain is wired together
um
so you said you were going to defend
tick tock and i feel like you might join
i love the content that i see on tick
tock i find it more valuable than some
things i see on youtube i just watched
one yesterday and it was a girl
explaining what's going on with ukraine
and nato and she did it in a really
funny kind of almost like she was
gossiping to a friend about it and she
explained it in 60 seconds so concisely
and perfectly and made and entertain me
along the way so i think there is value
in the style of content there's value in
a platform like tick tock which you know
like it or not has done this really well
of serving you up content that it thinks
you will like and then keeping you
engaged
so on that side i mean that's just smart
marketing that's how the content machine
works it's why we love watching youtube
video after youtube video and now it's
now it's tick tock and so it sounds like
the meta lesson then is no pun intended
is parents have to continue to remain
parents because asking a 10 year old or
a 14 year old to
look at cooking videos over
salacious videos or extra violent
content or whatever
um it's it's
you're asking too much of a small kid
right yes i'm a grown man it's very
different for me versus a 13 year old
especially if you have kids out there i
can't imagine what it's like being a
parent and trying to you know make sure
that you're aware of what your kid is
engaging in what apps that they're
downloading and part of the all the
drama with tick tock is that there's no
no need for parents permission kids can
just download this app make their
account and have free rein over all the
content on there yeah
and man i
i trust you you're smart and you're wise
and you do your due diligence if
somebody said hey i've been getting a
lot of updates on what's going on
overseas
via tiktok
i would just shake my head in the
sadness you know what i mean yeah so
also be careful about what you're
getting too well this is their news
platform now yeah they're not checking
cnn and fox news anymore teens are just
going on tick tock that's great either
but and they're just learning from
people their age about what's going on
and so take everything with a grain of
salt yep tick tock is not gospel it is
not the dictionary so do your due
diligence but it's a fun entertaining
platform i use it to learn things and to
be entertained but if you've got a kid
out there you've got to be really
careful about how this is affecting your
teen with comparison culture and both
content-wise and neurologically right
yeah because it used to be i want to be
a youtuber john that's the new goal of
every high schooler now it's i want to
be a tick-tock influencer and i want to
make content what's my content going to
be how am i going to hook people in and
they get obsessed with this with all the
likes all the engagement all the
comments and all the critics and every
negative comment that comes through that
affects you mentally that's what sticks
with especially kids right dave and i
just read mean tweets yesterday it
doesn't affect us like it would a
teenager you know we'd have thicker skin
than i did at 14 years old well you
remember a few things people said to you
when you were 14 right there's a comment
that still sticks with me when i was 14
i uploaded a youtube video and they said
it was it was a me covering umbrella by
rihanna on acoustic guitar and they said
you killed it dot dot dot and not in a
good way
and it stuck with me because it was
funny it was creative and it hurt but
there's something about these strangers
that are critics on the internet and we
take it personally and go this is a
reflection on my character and who i am
and so you've got to be really careful
not just about what you're posting what
you're engaging in but what other people
are saying that you don't even know
so man i just loot back to two big
things number one if you're wondering
can i have a job can i have a life if i
don't engage in this
i don't and i seem to be doing okay and
the second thing is
please be highly diligent with your kids
just hand in your kid a device or a box
a digital babysitter and saying go get
them and make good choices
is
just a recipe for disaster that the data
on children's mental health and their
engagement with social media continues
to just be jaw-dropping i think it's
going to be one of the biggest issues
for that generation that we've got to
grapple with
and parents are the start of it they've
got to have these conversations